welcome to this video playing tort off
from Argentina let's see check the bogo
now let's transpose to an Enzo I'm I
just have a bit more experience on the
white side of the NIMS oh then the night
of three lines hmm now this I don't have
any experience in hmm interesting it's
quite comparable to the Queen's Indian
but he has played d6 instead of b6 ok
yeah of course I need to fight yes but
what about Queen a4 check check hmm hmm
I think I get this Bishop take back
requested handle not at five minutes
Jess come on if we start with that kind
of stuff I'm rated 2600 by the end of
the week no no come on yeah well I don't
hate really don't know I cannot I cannot
accept take back so this is serious
chest so let's see what what happens
here I'm I'm a piece of a team is not
resigning let's try to open up the H
file use the extra piece for for some
attack
I really don't mind to accept take backs
and in all the time control games if it
is an obvious mouse slip for instance
but he just blundered the piece I mean
if you sometimes you have those cases
where you that's that's an accidental
King move like in the middle of the
middle of the board and you know okay
this guy wanted to play the no castles
and not kinky two or something then I do
that but if you expect to have them take
bags after blunders then probably just
try another game black resigned yeah
well not the most exciting came ever but
he's writing to me scared yeah they're
not scared i'm playing a serious game
here this is sports not some kind of I
don't know coin flipping you'd be
blunder piece you need to suffer for it
I mean as I mentioned if I would start
to ask for take backs i mean i don't
know if i get 2 2 a rating that i never
see it that's all before yeah okay this
is the nevertheless an interesting
position you should probably just just
take Stan maybe take on c3 Knight f6
something like that that's unclear yeah
well these kind of games happen thanks
for watching